er ist ein sehr netter spaziergang
da fragen wir sind bei der bank
beteiligt der bankdirektor gibt einen
check aus für 2,6 milliarden und er
behauptet er dürfte das ohne die
eigentümer der bank zu fragen darüber
streiten
[Musik]
wir können ja nur bewerten was die
richter fragen die fragen haben deutlich
gemacht dass sie es ja genau prüfen ob
die europäische zentralbank ihre
kompetenzen überschritten hat und sie
prüfen auch ob es wirklich richtig ist
was der sagt dass dieser europäische
zentralbank ihre kompetenzen selbst
bestimmen kann
bisher dachten wir alle die sind
eigentlich durch verbindliche verträge
von 19 euro staaten festgelegt
zusätzlich wissen wir dass das
bundesverfassungsgericht im juli 2017 in
dem vorlagebeschluss schon sehr deutlich
gemacht hat dass es die thesen von uns
klägern unterstützt
dass nämlich der bundeshaushalt die
bundesrepublik deutschland nicht
finanzieller art eingehen darf ohne dass
es zu einem beschluss der
parlamentarisch gesetzgeberischen
gremien kommt und ist alles
zusammengefasst macht uns mut dass
münster durchsetzen können
[Musik]
dass ein gericht durch ein anderes
gericht aufgehoben wird ist keine
premiere sondern das ist das schicksal
von richter und dieses checks und
balance zwischen den gerichten macht
eigentlich erst den rechtsstaat aus bei
der auslegung der verträge hat der
europäische gerichtshof ein problem bei
der frage der verfassungskonvent der
rechtsstaatlichen konstitution bewegen
sich beide gerichte auf gleicher
augenhöhe da kann es schon mal vorkommen
dass die gerichte sich wechselseitig
unterschiedliche bewertungen an den kopf
werden bei uns in der bundeswehr
deutschland ist die oberste instanz für
die auslegung des grundgesetzes des
grundgesetzes als grundgesetzes dts das
bundesverfassungsgericht und die
bestimmen was die bundesregierung oder
die bundesbank zu tun zu unterlassen hat
und wenn das bundesverfassungsgericht
sagt an dieser art von ankaufprogramm
nicht vor 26 millionen ohne vorherige
prüfung dürft ihr euch nicht mehr
beteiligen dann geht's halt nicht mehr
[Musik]
es ist bitter juristerei wie bei der
krankengymnastik
man muss immer wieder hin drücken bis
der muskel in bewegung kommt wir geben
hier nicht nach und es ist ja gestern
auch durch die vertreter der bundesbank
die der europäischen zentralbank was
gutes tun wollten in der
gerichtsverhandlung freimütig eingeräumt
worden dass ohne bisherige laden sie gar
nicht so weit gekommen mit einigermaßen
haftungsbegrenzung die alle noch nicht
weit genug gehen
aber das zeigt dass dieses geschäft aber
muss ich schon leicht
das gute